the formal remembrance of an american
hero congressman john lewis is about to
begin
the civil rights icon died last week at
the age of 80.
lewis was a leader of the freedom riders
and a protege of martin luther king jr
in his struggle to fight against racial
segregation lewis often faced arrest
and violence this morning lewis's body
left atlanta and is on its way to
alabama
our own michelle miller is leading the
network's coverage of today's events
in selma michelle good morning yet again
good morning dana there is nearly a
week's worth of events
and tributes planned for john lewis
beginning this morning it all begins
about 90 miles from here
with services in troy alabama lewis's
hometown
as a young man john lewis was denied
admission to troy university because of
the color of his skin
it was indignant in dignity such as that
that fueled his lifelong pursuit of
justice and equality
from there lewis's body will be brought
here to selma
site of the 1965 civil rights march that
was met with violence by police
lewis's skull was fractured as he led
peaceful marchers
across the edmund pettus bridge on what
became known as
bloody sunday a flash point in the civil
rights movement
tomorrow a funeral procession will carry
lewis
over the bridge one last time lewis body
will lie in state at the alabama state
capital of montgomery tomorrow night
he will receive the same honor on monday
and tuesday
at the united states capitol where he
served as a member of the house of
representatives
for more than 30 years from there it
will be one final trip
back to atlanta the city he represented
in congress all those years
lewis will lie in state in georgia's
capitol on wednesday
then on thursday a final tribute to
lewis
will be held at the ebenezer baptist
church the church once led by his mentor
dr martin luther king jr the public will
be allowed to pay their respects at some
of these events
but due to the pandemic lewis family has
encouraged supporters
to live stream the events and a tie a
purple or blue ribbon
on their door in their yards to pay
tribute to him
what a lovely thought have you gotten
your ribbons yet
indeed it is michelle thank you very
much